we're going to begin with this we're
hearing more scathing criticism of
President Trump today from a former key
member of his inner circle in an ABC
News interview former national security
adviser John Bolton claims mr. Trump
makes most of his decisions based on
what's in his best interest not the
country's Tony bolt Bolden said he won't
be voting for a president Trump in
November he had voted for him in 2016
now he says he's concerned about the
direction of our country I hope it will
remember him as a one-term president who
didn't plunge the country irretrievably
into a downward spiral we can't recall
from over the weekend a federal judge
cleared Bolton's memoir for publication
tomorrow after the Trump administration
tried to block it the room where it
happened is published by Simon &
Schuster which happens to be a division
of Viacom CBS CBS News senior national
security contributor Michael Morell was
the former acting and deputy director of
the CIA Michael good morning thanks for
being with us what did John Bolton's
allegations what would John Bolton's
allegations say to you about about the
way this White House functions so
Anthony before reading the book just
reading the media talking to my friends
I understood that there was a level of
dysfunction in this administration but
after having read the book after having
watched the interview last night I'd
have to say that that level of
dysfunction is historic lack of
attention by the president lack of
interest in any details inconsistent
directives to his senior officials
changing his mind on final policy
decisions going outside his set of
advisors for confidential advice it all
adds up to dysfunction and to me the
title of the book is wrong it's not the
room where it happened it's total chaos
Boulton says that Russian President
Vladimir Putin played the president like
a fiddle what's your reaction to that
that's absolutely correct he had he did
it before the election I even he was the
first foreign leader to figure out the
way to get what he wanted from the
president which his stroke his ego
give him the photo opportunities he
wants given the pageantry he wants now
many other leaders have learned that not
surprising Anthony that he was the first
to learn it given that he was a former
intelligence officer and he was trained
to figure out what people want to hear
so that you can get what you want
according to Bolton took very good notes
from what we understand while he was in
the White House
Michael a he said that in intelligence
briefings the president actually only
attended them once or twice a week is
that unusual it's highly unusual thus
most presidents take their intelligence
briefing every day when i briefed george
w bush it was six days a week it was
scheduled for a half hour and often went
an hour and on weekends at Camp David it
went for two hours so there was deep
deep interest many many questions what
john bolton describes as few briefings
and during those briefings most of the
time the president did the talking
not the briefers and most of the time it
was about issues that had nothing to do
with national security when when you
when you see what bolton essentially
describes as a very conspicuous lack of
attention to detail what do you think
the impact on national security from
something like that is Michael you can't
you can't make good national security
decisions without a rigorous
understanding of the situation and a
rigorous assessment of the policy
options and the upsides of those options
and the downsides of those options you
have to read a lot it's absolutely clear
from reading Bolton's book that the
President did none of that that the
president really relies on his gut on
his instinct and he's making a final
assessment based on what's in his
interests not what's in the net
shanell interests and I think you know
as I read the book John Bolton is pretty
compelling on that point it's very
convincing the government has been
fighting the release of this book
because they say it contains classified
information you're very familiar with
classified information is there anything
in here that raises alarm bells to you
so there were a number of things as I
read the book that jumped out to me that
I have not seen before these would be
facts about our adversaries and I don't
know whether they're classified but I
have not seen them before and they seem
to come from intelligence sources so it
is quite possible Anthony that there is
classified information in this book all
right Michael Morell thank you so much
for being with us this morning